[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up fair Monday morning welcome
to the program kids how was your weekend
how's everybody doing kids are back in
school all right everything's back to
normal for the most part it's good to
see everybody glad everybody's doing
well how about House of dragons last
night pretty lit about time we got our
kind of our version of the the uh what
was that what were they called the the
red something
um the Red Wedding kind of I mean
granted red wedding so many people died
but in that um
nobody died but it was lit
um yeah man fresh off the boat from
Boston my favorite city outside of
California I absolutely love Boston
there I am dude I'm on freak I'm in I'm
in Fenway bro I took over Fenway me and
the boys we got there we were dishing
out some tiger thick to the locals
because you know they like their whiskey
down there they like their Brew hahas
Fenway is a sick ass place Fenway is
really special man it's just old school
over there I love it even the ticket
booths are still old we're just
strolling around the town
um
yeah Fenway was cool I wish there was a
game there they were out of town if
there's a game during the day I could
have went I had the best lobster all my
life but the problem was it was a brown
butter lobster roll it was I'm trying to
be it was this big and the guy's like
yeah you might want to order a ton of
them and I was like whatever but he's
not lying we should order a ton of them
but it was the best laughter of my life
I ate at the infamous uh uh oyster or
something you remember the name the
oyster Union the oyster unions the
oldest restaurants from like 18 30 some
[ __ ] in Boston it's been there forever
and
um we called to get reservations because
everyone told me to go there and they
sat us in the seat that JFK because that
was you know he's a Massachusetts boy he
uh he had that's one of his favorite
restaurants and he'd always sit in the
same seat every time and they sat us in
the JFK Booth which I appreciate and uh
it has like his picture on it and he can
order the JFK drink he's drink this
Martini Jay drank it it was in music it
was cool man I appreciate the not gonna
lie the food there was okay the lobster
roll there was a little dry it was it
was way too big there it is that's where
your boy's sitting right in that exact
seat nice yeah the JFK seat man and they
have their own JFK drinks I just
absolutely love Boston man rough
Newberry Street went to sell my boys at
a concept Concepts
like a streetwear street you know
skateboard it was it's just a dope place
man they all came out to the to the
shows
um
my boy's gonna drink all his stock you
ain't lying dude
um those are the concept Vans there the
concepts of those these dope collabs
that's the Vans there they're coming out
soon
yeah a lot of tiger thick going on out
there in Boston and then tiger thick
will be available at the shows in San
Jose which is next weekend San Jose
Improv you're up next next weekend next
next Thursday Friday Saturday San Jose
weekend after that be in Salt Lake City
one of my favorite venues at the Wise
Guys and they will have a thick Boy
available there then we end uh the
October tour in Calgary Canada Calgary
the rooftop downtown Calgary that's
October 27th that's a Thursday one show
only but because that bad boy is a boom
and we're gonna add a show on that
Friday on the 28th at the rooftop again
so get your tickets and then hopefully
your boy can fly back early enough
Saturday morning on the 29th so we do a
fight companion
for uh Jake Paul verse Anderson Silva
there's also something else on what else
is on the 29th there's also another is
the UFC there's UFC on 29th let's see is
there a UFC on training there's some on
the 29th too because that could be a
double header
like yeah that might be a double I felt
like there's some on the 29th let's take
a look oh is it Calvin kator and uh
Arnold Allen that's what it is
yeah might have to do that double
might have to that double on our Arnold
Allen Calvin Kate or that's a hell of a
fight not I'm not crazy about that fight
for my boy Taylor that's my guy yeah New
England's finest and you see I'm rocking
that Triple O's Lounge shirt this is
Whitey bulger's favorite bar it's not
there anymore now it's a hot yoga place
all right Charleston's changed a little
bit Southeast changed a little bit
things are different there
we have a bit hitting Green Room Diaries
it'll come out hopefully today or
tomorrow about uh how Boston has changed
and some other stuff it was a fun one
though man shout out to Boston like I
said I always do The Wilburn Boston
Wilbur's probably the best theater in
the country and uh it's just I don't get
to see boss as much as I'd like so we
did a we did a club this time and did
laugh Boston and there ain't nothing
like a club in Boston it was a good vibe
it was a good experience shout out to
Boston shot everybody who came out
everyone's so nice there too man
everyone was dope we did a lot of
walking around there a lot of walking in
Boston I brought my boys back uh they
always asked for jerseys you know
because they're kids and obviously
Boston right so he's he doesn't have any
Red Sox gear he was crunk super crunk
right look at him super crunk totally
crunk yeah right super crunk for his
gear it's a little long though it's the
small side they had he's a thick boy but
he's a little thick little thick monster
so that just a little too long for him
but uh there was some let's get into the
fights man there's some fights this
weekend
um I told you guys the most exciting
card of the weekend was gonna be one
Championship it didn't disappoint I
thought it was a great uh just overall
from top to bottom a great card
um gotta be honest being a vet maybe I'm
a little biased let's see what you guys
think but Nan versus Angela Lee this is
the a rubber match
um they ended up giving Nan the
unanimous decision which I disagree with
I think Nan
um clearly clear as day won that first
round after that though I'm up to I'm up
to here the debate that it was uh you
know three to two in Angela Lee's
um
you know did her again the decision I'm
up for three to two there's an argument
before to one for Angel Lee for for the
judges to give to Nan unanimously is
insane to them insane
and their scoring is based off it's a
little different than here in the states
and in the UFC I mean is where they
don't score it round by round the score
like overall fight kind of like the
pride rules remember that like the pride
stuff okay let's go off that scoring
criteria how do you give it to Nan
and she only really did the damage in
the first round but another four Andrew
Lee was chucking and driving moving
submission threats like putting on the
pressure going forward you know octagon
control
um I guess if you're just predicating
off one round of damage you would give
to Nan
skeptical hip wise man skeptical hip
wise it ain't right it ain't right at
all I thought Angelique kind of got
screwed over there and then Mikey doing
the damn thing uh that has to be kind of
a milestone for jiu jitsu that's a big
deal your co-main event straight on Jiu
Jitsu first everyone too yep and your
boy Mikey got it done
um stamp Fair text is a badass you saw
the elbow she's a monster but the whole
card was good man you got that and then
you had uh Bellator which is a hell of a
card too belter is pretty
pretty stacked Patricio doing the damn
thing uh he would get he was getting
booed which he didn't care about and
then AJ McKee still doing the damn thing
uh My Boy Aaron Pico who you guys know I
love Aaron Pico uh his shoulder fell off
huh his shoulder fell off fell off and
then his coaches are way too into Lethal
Weapon and they're like oh what we'll do
is exactly
what Mel Gibson did in the movie and
he's got to Ram it back in that looks so
painful man
is that and is that six gun is that yeah
Brandon Gibson jacking it back in and
apparently he got it back in
yeah
so Aaron Pico was asking he's going to
pop his arm back in place
yeah I don't know uh listen I'm not a
doctor hey guys this is giving me news
to a few of you out there I'm not a
doctor I just feel like that's not the
best way to do it I mean you can pop the
shoulder back get lined up pop back in
but like jerking on it like that you're
it's only going to cause more ligament
and like structural damage I would
assume yeah again not doctor I've
listened to Six Gun over me all day and
maybe he's done it he's listening he's
cornered a million guys so maybe he's
done before and the guy went back out
there won the fight but it's just a
shame for Aaron Pico they got to run
that back you gotta run it back just
mpgo has these things you know that
prevent him from being you know living
up to his full potential the stuff he
can do when your freaking shoulder pops
out
um yeah I I would assume doctors kind of
chimed in and was like hey don't do that
he's not Mel Gibson this isn't Hollywood
he's not Mel Gibson from Lethal Weapon
ramming his shoulder into the wall to
pop it back in you can't do that right
hopefully he's okay
and Pico uh I was thinking about him I
think I even brought it up to a bow
nickel you haven't seen the bow nickel
food truck diary it dropped on Thursday
of last week some of my favorite food
trucks ever
so we have a million guys come through
here right Champions and you know
prospects and contenders and all this
stuff and I've always been a fan for of
bow nickel for a while now and then you
get him in here you're like oh this guy
has that that quiet confidence he's just
he just has it man he just has it and
then the thing I think I'm most excited
about is if you listen to the show
before I talk about how the UFC is going
to have a problem because I don't have
like really any big American Stars a lot
of their stars are long in the tooth
they were pay-per-view Stars UFC's gone
away from the pay-per-view model now
that Mickey Mouse is their boss and they
just have to put on fights right so you
have this again it's not a problem
because these guys are super talented
and monsters but you have this surgeons
of Russians dagestanians that that kind
of style that's taken with UFC if you
look at magamed at light heavyweight
probably gonna be a champ uh you look at
um homeboy makachev at 155 good chance
to meet a champ
um which we would get into with Charles
Oliver which made tougher testing things
you know you had Peter John doing the
thing you have all these guys surging up
from Dagestan and these Savages you have
uh hamzat you know um who's uh chechnyan
you know but that area that Vibe right
and um
that's what's booming in the UC you have
all this town all this talent coming of
Dagestan and Russia and that area of the
world in their absolute Savages
let's take a little break for me
chatting your ear off about the fight
game uh on tour San Jose you're up next
weekend next Thursday Friday Saturday
San Jose California is October 13th
through the 15th Salt Lake City Wise
Guys Salt Lake City my favorite venues
October 20th through 22nd then I close
the month out in Calgary Calgary Canada
I'm at the rooftop downtown Calgary
Canada we had a show on the 27th which
is almost sold out so we added Sean 28th
that's in Calgary baby your boys coming
up to Calgary November is a very Texas
heavy San Antonio Houston then I'm in
Jeffrey Dahmer's Hometown in Milwaukee
but uh Santo Texas and then Houston
Texas you're up in November but coming
up San Jose next week Thursday Friday
Saturday get Joe tickets NorCal the NFL
action is in full swing at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL we talking touchdowns
big plays even bigger wins new customers
can bet just five dollars on any NFL
team to win and get 200 in free bets if
they do check this out you'll you're
like oh I need more okay I got you Daddy
everyone can boost their winnings with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
we got you man to make things even
sweeter you can throw down on stepped up
same game parlays once per game
all season long download the draft game
sportswear app right now use promo code
shop show that's schab show to get 200
in free bets if your team wins when you
place a five dollar bet on any football
game that's code shop show only at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting part of the NFL minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details lately I've been I
just been cruising on my bike man my
road bike I converted to a trail bike
and I'm just out in nature and I'm
listening to podcasts I'm listening to
music a lot of the odd posts pictures of
me out there on the trails being the
thick boy bike club president man you
get you use wires on your on your
earbuds what are you doing dude who uses
wires are you from the early 2000s it's
my ears my hair looks like a tortellini
so I can't use the wireless earbuds
until my friends at raycon wireless
earbuds they came along and their
raycons everyday earbuds look feels
sound better than ever and this is what
helps me out they're optimized gel tips
it's the perfect in-ear it these earbuds
are so comfortable they will not budge
trust me your boys on the trail shaking
and they're staying in raycons give you
eight hours of Play Time a 32 hour
battery life raycons are priced just
right you get quality audio at half the
price of the other premium audio Brands
so no wonder raycons everyday earbuds
have over 50 000 five-star reviews
they're fantastic it's noise isolation
they've got awareness mode for you and
you cannot you can also they have the
ear tap functions which I love when I'm
on my bike go to buy raycon.com that's
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n.com today use code
shop 15 you get 15 off raycon earbuds
that's right that's code shop15 at buy
raycon.com to score 15 off buy
raycon.com code shop15 but I don't know
if that's gonna you know really get
Americans excited about it we haven't
had big time Americans come about you
know if you look at all the Champions
there's not a ton of Americans man
there's not right
so we need something to counter that
to for a for entertainment B just to
keep it going here in America because
right now the UFC is not really focused
in America their biggest focus is
outside internationally because they
have all these International Stars so
who is going to save the day it's Bo
nickel
bone echo's your guy bow nickel is the
face of the UFC for the future he is a
guy that
um has all the talent in the world has
all talent in the world has the
background has the the merits and he
speaks well because you gotta remember
and he allude to this on the fight
um the fight Diaries um food truck Dyers
that you know he grew up doing marketing
so at Penn State wrestling is everything
and when you he wasn't just a wrestler
there he was the wrestler there so he
had to be the guy who was the voice for
wrestling he's the face of wrestling
he's a face of Penn State so he's doing
interviews with these big time companies
so he's familiar with the camera he
speaks well he looks good dresses well
and then he also has the skills to back
it up he's a profession now and not only
he's a professional but he realizes his
kind of
job and he knows that he has a chance to
do something very special and you have
these dagestanians are taking over stuff
like that now remember Bo nickel was
wrestling those guys on the world tour
circuit he's he wasn't just beating
those guys he's Tech fouling those guys
he's dominating those guys so those guys
and they're wrestling
the matabo nickel now for every other
American that kind of screwed with it
but for that guy he's not worried about
the wrestling so he's a guy that we can
invest stock and invest promotional uh
assets to and build them up because he
is going to be the face of the UFC in
the next three years and his come up is
going to be fantastic and now they did
announce a fight
with bow nickel
um he's fighting in December and
God bless the guy that took the fight
because
you know if you're to correlate Beau
Nichols talent and trajectory compared
to where he's ranked you know this is
basically like Alabama playing you know
like Savannah State
[Music]
you know what I'm saying it's like
you look at the schedule right if if
Fighters were you know football teams
you look at their schedule this is going
to be an out of conference game he's
fighting a you know a tough guy but Bo
nickel should absolutely mop the floor
with this gentleman Now Grant he has a
he has a good amount of fights so he's
fighting Jimmy Pickett and this is no
District Jimmy pick in any facet so uh
if it's a middleweight
um his a bow Neck overs Jimmy picks me
on you'll see 282
and that is in Vegas I assume
I think so we'll see keep going down uh
so uh I think Jamie pink is on a
two-fight losing streak as well
um and what's his background chin let me
see his record
point is is you know Bo nickel is asking
for hamzat Bo Nichols asking for anybody
in the top ten Bo nickel
you know we broke it on thick boy fight
news respond to Darren till then till
don't want them problems Dental does not
want those problems so
um so here's Pickett
um
so background lovers lived with his
grandparents growing up his father being
in prison his mom a drug user leaving
his family so this is this kid's a
success story no matter what happens in
this fight so his record he's 13-8 his
21 total fights so he's a veteran he's a
brown belt in jiu jitsu
okay
um ultimately if I made his uh
promotional debut
um so he lost his uh first fight and
then he lost his second fight okay I'm
surprised they kept him
um so he won his second fight uh he won
his third fight
won his fourth fight
then he got choked out with a darsh
choke against Marquez uh the Cuban
Missile Crisis and then his last one
picolas fight TKO second round a nice
fighting Bo nickel
okay
it's gonna be a tough go for him it's a
tough go for no wrestling background
either so
it's gonna be tough you know but that's
how this goes and I bet I would be
willing to bet that the the UFC the
matchmakers whoever was at uh Nick
Maynard or Sean Shelby whoever is
dealing with Bo nickel and the you know
the matchups I bet they asked a few guys
to take this fight against him and they
said no so Bo nickel I don't know how
many they're going to be able to do like
this because these guys now granted
this dude uh Jamie Pickett has no
leverage so he has to take the fight if
he were to say no they're gonna cut him
right supposed to be coming off the Lost
they're going to cut him so these guys
are forced to take the fight
the problem is with Bo is you're gonna
see what he does to freaking this guy
and so after that I want like how much
longer so I would assume they give him
another test a guy on maybe a three
fight streak but not in the top 15. he's
gonna get probably two to three fights
like this depending how how slow the UFC
wants to play it but it's just a matter
of time like how many times are you guys
gonna tune in and watch Alabama play
Savannah State or apple Appalachian
State Appalachian State's a good team
but how many times you can tune into
that eventually the fans are going to
demand especially if he's walking
through like butter especially if he's
doing to these guys what he's doing on
the contender series just absolutely
starching them eventually the neighbors
gonna be like all right you'll see let's
go here they're gonna Force UFC's hand
to get him against top 15 guy
Bo's ready to go
fight is he right now a fight Canon
there like you look at the top ten
I know I'm a bow nickel dick rider that
big red rocket dick of his I'm a fan of
and you look at the top top ten
you tell me who's beating them
I would love to hear it
Alex Pierre is fighting Izzy right
quick question for the crew here Alex
Pier is ranked number four
what do you think Bona could do ask beer
oh wait go ahead
they catapulted Alex Pierre to a title
shot for the story of Izzy if I spares
to beat Izzy the officers do a rematch
but after that he fights anyone with
grappling Jared Cannon air Marvin
Victoria's getting pretty young Derek
brunson's a pretty ugly for him
so the point is is Bo Nick was an awful
matchup for the majority of the top 10.
awful match-up awful match-up there's
also you know and it doesn't get to a
guy like Bo Nick because he's been in
high pressure situations since he was
six again watch the food truck die you
see what I'm talking about since he was
six he's been under high pressure so now
this stuff gets to him so they can't
move them along fast enough and usually
you know even when we had Laura sanco on
food truck I was like here's my plan
give him the experience let you know let
him take his time but he's just this
special talent where the UFC who's
predominantly known for Russian guys you
see what they've done with Darren Taylor
you know they've been Russian rushing
and they've learned from their mistakes
you look at what they've done with sugar
Shawn doing with Patty pimlet right
Bo nickel is different than those two
he's different he's a guy you can rush
and I would be okay with it for the
first time
now it's a it's a marathon not a Sprint
but also you could you could speed it up
with this guy you'd speed it up with
this guy let's see how he does on his
first pay-per-view also don't put my boy
on the pre-lims UFC listen whatever we
have our issues do not put [ __ ] bow
nickel on the prelims
don't do that
his fight when he when he was uh before
his own condensers they put him on fight
night it was the most viewed fight
that entire year on Fight Pass is the
most viewed thing on Fight Pass
that's he brings a freaking fan base
people want to see this guy fight now
he's on a pretty stacked card you got
Robbie Lawler uh putzanibio you got
shabazian
um TJ brander Silva yeah duplessy Darren
till
rosenstrue Chris uh Dukakis Chris Curtis
Joaquin Buckley
uh Da Silva Bo nickel Jimmy Pickett you
got do not put my boy bow nickel if he's
the main event on the prelim like and
can't see that he should kick off the
Pay-Per-View
and then have dinner until go after him
you know because I would assume
um Bo nickel who's never met a Mike he
doesn't like and he's pretty good on
that thing I'd assume he uh gets on
there and calls out uh Darren too or
homeboy beats there until he'll fight
him but they're eventually the UFC's
issue is going to be these big boys
turning the fights down against bow
nickel that's what they're going to run
into
kid is a Savage and
ATT has set him up so he doesn't have to
leave College Station in Pennsylvania
where he trains out of here's a whole
Factory there and it's they're all
little bow nickels now not to his level
he's talking about a guy who won Big Ten
athlete of the year so all he hasn't
Ohio State Penn State football Michigan
State basketball Ohio State basketball
Ohio State football he beat out those
boys Northwestern you look at the Big
Ten Conference Wisconsin football
straight up best athlete that's what
you're dealing with we've never seen
anything like this I think he's the
biggest Prospect to ever fight in the
UFC
average fighting you see forgot to have
what you have [ __ ] it's three fights
in ten Shades two so five fights total
but three legit fights and Contender
series
biggest Prospect we've ever had
ever
see they have three fights
yeah so that that his first fight
against John Nolan uh which was on Jorge
Mazda's icon fc3 that's on Fight Pass
most watch fight
that fight pass this had yet
that's the demand for bow nickel you
can't put them on pre-lips you just
can't you're dealing with different
animals there's a demand there you don't
put that guy in prelims I know ESPN's
gonna like oh cool we got views no no
you you don't disrespect Beau nickel
like that he'll remember that he's gonna
be the face of your company man you need
that guy to rejuvenate the Americans you
need that guy to be the face and he's
your guy so I feel sorry for all these
guys have to fight them all these
Appalachian States all these Savannah
states that have to you know play
against Alabama enjoy that my man it's
gonna be a nightmare
let me try for that card though
super excited for that card and I know
they were talking about we were talking
about off-eared what's next for him so
there's the UFC's only be able to get
away with it for maybe one more time
after this depending how he walks
through this fire now the pressure is on
him because if you've done absolutely
annihilate this guy if he gets hit right
people are gonna start talking but those
people can never please so I know he
doesn't give a [ __ ] but it's just a
matter of time man if you understand
what they do with them
um so yeah so you did long story short
you had some a UFC fight this weekend
you had Mackenzie Dern versus
um homegirl uh John
um yep and the main event Kenzie during
fun some tough times right she tuned to
our last four fights
she says she needs to get meaner with
submission she's a really nice person
and I understand that that can
definitely be a detriment to your career
when you don't have that killer instinct
and she doesn't appear to have that
which can be a problem though the
problem is the Striking I know she's
getting better the problem is when
you're that Elite at Jitsu but you're
training striking wrestling so much you
fall in love and want to show off your
hard work of striking instead of doing
what makes you special which is the
Jujitsu and she she's got her some tough
times but at the level she's fighting at
and she's even allude to the center post
fight press conference these girls
aren't going to tap man you gotta you
gotta go For Broke you gotta have Frank
Merritt you gotta Frank Merritt like
Frank says even training it's not on me
you know if the guy breaks his arm the
guy breaks his own I trained to snap
[ __ ] off and they if they tap all good
you're he was the only reason they're
tapping is because they don't want to
have their arm broken but they know if
they don't tap that I'm gonna get broken
even in training he's like because you
have to train him that way and that's
why I tell he tells his daughter who's a
Savage
that when you get it you get it to break
it you're not doing it to do it until
they tap you're not waiting for them to
tap you're going in and you're breaking
it as soon as they tap it you let go you
don't be that crazy training partner
who's breaking your you know toys
because you have nobody to play with or
nothing to play with but you know you
got to do it to to the full extent and
it's on your training partner to tap so
maybe MacKenzie didn't take a page out
of Frank Mayer's book you know and Frank
mayor is on uh Fight Night flashbacks my
favorite one because you know the guy's
a [ __ ] Legend he goes through we go
through him snapping Tim Sylvia's arm
stepping big nogs the [ __ ] knee bars
Brock Lesnar he goes through all of it
and I'm like holy [ __ ] man look at the
torque and he goes yeah yeah every I'm
trying to break the [ __ ] arm every
single time I'm not just doing it the
hope they tap and I get out I'm
literally doing it to deactivate that
limb on their body Mackenzie during
could use some of that energy in her
fights because she's getting these girls
in certain positions and she's just not
Frank Marinette that's what she's doing
that comes out this Wednesday boom Fight
Night flashbacks Frank mayor drops
Wednesday me and Frank mayor could have
done a six hour podcast me and him can
but we're both some chatty Catholics
he's such an interesting dude he's a fun
one and a legend and all the knowledge
he's a smart guy you know and he coaches
his daughter who's this [ __ ] Savage
wrestling at Iowa and you know she's
just this monster man monster she's a
champion here or she's a champion Vegas
like monster monster such a talent so
it's interesting let's take a little
break fam because listen it's fall fall
is popping and the ladies and the men's
out there you're getting your pumpkin
spice latte but the one thing you're
forgetting is that crotch man that's
right the leaves are falling why not let
that bush fall too on your body talking
about the the hair around that wiener
trunk my friends at manscape they got
you covered man listen manscape has
helped over six million Bros worldwide
that's how many dudes trust manscape by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping when they were using the
code shop 20 20 off dude whether you're
brand new or already a part of the squad
with manscape you could use the crown
jewel of your care for your family
jewels I'm talking about that Platinum
4.0 package what's in it
oh my god I've never listened to a show
you hit the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer
you get the weed whacker nose air hair
trimmer all right in addition to that
you also get the body wash Ultra Premium
two in one shampoo conditioner we got
you covered man you're a premium
deodorant it smells nice all right and
they also got the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop reviver all right so
your balls are all sweaty not anymore
man they're fresh they're new they're
nice manscape even threw in two free
gifts with this Platinum package 4.0 the
manscape boxes and shed travel bag
they're made to hold all your goodies
all right go to manscape.com get 20 off
and free shipping with code shop20 that
swimsoft with free shipping at
manscape.com we use the code shop20
manscape clear out the leaves it's your
tree trunks time to shine I'll tell you
what man after years a fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by the
big Wireless providers if we've learned
anything is that there's always a catch
so when I first heard that mint mobile
offers premium Wireless starting at just
15 bucks a month 15 and I get the same
benefits all these fancy big name brands
see those dumb commercials on mint
mobile I thought what's the catch here
but after talking to them and using
their service which I've been doing for
two months now it makes sense there's no
catch mint mobile is the only service
that doesn't have a catch the secret
sauce that the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the cost of retail stores and they
pass those sweet savings directly to you
all right these other providers there's
always a catch and possibly contracts
the family plans all that stuff
Mobile's not doing that there's no brick
and mortar store you get it directly to
you from online sales so they don't have
all that overhead so they can give you
cheaper deals for anyone who hates their
phone bill mint mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 a month mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or the entire family the
family plan check out mint mobile all
right family lines are just two lines
all right families start at two lines
you can build from there all plans come
with unlimited talk and text high speed
data delivered on nation's largest 5G
Network use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with your existing contacts
you only do all that stuff which is
overwhelming it was so easy for me to do
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service time at just 15 a month
to get your new Wireless plan for 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
that's mintmobile.com cut your wireless
this bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com job all you sports fans
out there you've heard of your favorite
athlete the captain of the team the dude
slang that pink skin of the dudes
throwing Spinning Wheel kicks or the
dude hitting home runs non-stop you hear
him talking about the Flow State being
in the zone well you can be in the zone
whatever job you have you don't have to
just be a world star athlete now man to
be in the zone means you're crushing it
you're focused you're not no
distractions how do you get in the zone
though people ask that how can that flow
State how are you in that zone how do I
slow things down focus on Project well
there's no Tropics yep there's
nootropics it's by the best company on
the planet I'm talking about on it on
it.com all right audit.com you save
temps off I'm talking about Alpha Brain
that's right Alpha Brain you've heard of
it you've heard of it you've heard my
boy Joe Rogan talk about it so it helps
them form better senses when he's
talking Alpha Brain is the real deal man
it helps your brain
fire away helps you remember names and
also it's caffeine free and here's the
thing they're so confident that's going
to work you can try alphabet if you
don't like it you get your money back
you skim two weeks and they don't charge
you anything you get all your money back
and you keep the freaking bottle they're
like whatever man they're from the money
on the spot no return necessary that's
how confident on it is in Alpha Brain go
to freaking audit.com you get temps off
your entire order but especially on
Alpha Brain all right and if you want to
not use that and to waste your life and
go to Walmart and pick it up in person
go to your local Walmart because they
also contain Alpha Brain but if you want
to save 10 off do it the right way go to
onnit.com 10 off Alpha Brain my daily
cheat code you're welcome the main
takeaway of that UFC Fight Night with
MacKenzie Dern John is if you were
following it and again this isn't a big
card so maybe some of you guys didn't
see this so I'll break it down for you
Mackenzie during on her press conference
goes yeah it's interesting Mark
Zuckerberg rented out the entire arena
for the fight night right
so Mark Zuckerberg spot case at UC uh 61
despite Daylight's [ __ ] claim now
technically Dana White isn't full of
[ __ ] here because
he said that Mark Zuckerberg didn't just
rent out just for him
okay if we're looking at this there were
a few others in the crowd so it's not
just Mark Zuckerberg but also
do we think that Mackenzie Dern had this
weird elaborate conspiracy theory she
came up with and just pulled it out of
her ass
which is nice house but did she pull it
out of her ass going oh yeah Mark
zuckerick rented the entire Arena out
you guys think Mackenzie Dern had some
elaborate plan and just made that up and
set it at a press conference or do you
think there's some smoke there
do you think I don't know she's around
UFC officials somebody told her that
Mark Zuckerberg rented out the Apex
Center is that so far-fetched to think
and then obviously that struck a nerve
with Dana he goes that's complete
[ __ ] he didn't do that
and then you watch the fight on Saturday
and that's exactly what he did
so
it's strange to me
that it's okay for Dana to go against
his Fighters and you know devalue him
and oh they're he's lying or call
another guy a [ __ ] dummy because he
had a conspiracy about uc279 because
there's some smoke there again I have no
issues with Dana
but we've also fallen into this pattern
where he is a promoter right so have we
ever met a promoter that doesn't lie
name one that's never lied to you go
I'll wait
are you done you can't think of any cool
you guys are shouting into your cars as
you're driving a work list in this you
can't think of anyone me neither that's
what promoters do they lie their
businessmen the promoters and most
promoters are you know scum dude so
that's what they do it's just what they
do it's part of the gig
so my thing here is if clearly Dana lied
about this they clearly rented it out
which doesn't make a lot of sense to me
and for whatever reason I came
downstairs in the team why does this
piss me off why is it okay that Mark
Zuckerberg all of a suddenly started
noticing the UFC he's like I like the
UFC look at this this was like do me a
favor look up the next fight night I'm
renting the entire arena in a sense like
I don't know if it works like that it's
like it does for me because they just
play by a different set of rules it's
like he's Caesar from Gladiator like
he's walking walking Phoenix from
Gladiator which just this weird I don't
know what it's triggering to me when I
found that out and I think if I'm
Mackenzie Dern the reason she she
mentioned it because you're a main event
on the UFC fight card it's a big deal
now imagine this is such a big deal and
you thrive off the energy of the fans
and then you find out that this rich guy
who created Facebook who has lied
through his [ __ ] teeth about
suppressing information that he doesn't
agree with he lies and then finally on
Rogan was like we did make some mistakes
with the misinformation We Were In
Cahoots with the you know with the White
House which is insane and Twitter's the
same and YouTube's the same and this
will get demonetized so let me bring
this up I don't give a [ __ ] at this
point bring it on the thing is
is there something weird about a guy
because he owns a billion dollar company
and just recently found his passion in
MMA and Jiu Jitsu and it's just so
strange that he can go I like that sport
I'm renting it out now imagine you're
Mackenzie during the main event and that
arena is empty
because this privileged nerd from
Harvard created an app called Facebook
and all of a sudden fancies himself some
UFC and decides to rent out the arena
for your main event
and we're just all cool with it
for the first time ever no media nothing
now they've never done this for anybody
they've had Donald Trump in the arena
they've had Shaquille O'Neal they've had
Elon Musk they've had you they've had
some big [ __ ] names in that Arena man
now Grant this Apex sound a little
different I'm not talking about MGM I'm
not talking about T-Mobile Arena right
he rents out the Apex seats I don't know
[ __ ] 100 people or more than that but
300 people still you're the main event
and you thrive off the fans giving you
energy
but this rich kid Joffrey from Game of
Thrones goes I like that sport I'm
coming I want anybody else there mine
is this not a weird kind of like Old
School Rome dictator thing
and did you see Dana at one point after
the Mackenzie Dern fight in the main
event he looked over and Mark Zuckerberg
went like this
and then Dana was like kill her I'm just
making that he didn't do that but you
get to see that
I heard Mark Zuckerberg go when do the
lines come out isn't that weird Mark
Zucker went hey when do the lines and
when do the the chains with the balls on
them come out when do they start hitting
each other in the face and killing each
other and then went oh oh uh uh Mr
Zuckerberg this isn't Rome okay dude
this isn't the Coliseum nobody's dying
Zucker went well I should have paid a
little more it's insane I wonder what
the deal was you know what's the deal
here because Dana is
far right you know what I'm saying like
he's Mr Trump so his information again
suppressed but the UFC obviously he
doesn't bring some of the politics in
the UFC so is it just like I'll scratch
your back you scratch mine I'll let you
just sit here like the rich Joffrey from
Game of Thrones and watch it with your
wife who clearly isn't into it some guy
through a spinning back Fist and he I
thought she was gonna throw up
choose Kate side about to throw up
because two grown men were fighting she
was terrified
Mark Zuckerberg is like yes blood Death
kill him look at her terrify look at her
terrified
she's not into this [ __ ]
well yeah I can't oh my God that's not
even bad girl you got a safe one
and that Arena was empty
that Arena was empty man it sucks for
the fighters
what'd you say definitely not packed no
no and also I bet the other Facebook in
place like hey man we would have went or
it's like no mine no
he's just Joffrey from Game of Thrones
how far does this go
if you're you've hoped dude Zuckerberg
backed the [ __ ] up hopefully he's not a
bone nickel fan hopefully you know hope
he's not an Izzy fan how far is this
gonna go what if he becomes a big Izzy
fan Izzy's next Pay-Per-View fight it's
just Mark Zuckerberg in a giant Arena
like how far and he has all the money to
do it
for him what is it the gates whatever
like 13 million or something by the time
they sell that ain't [ __ ] he can do that
easily well he's like uh what if his
girl was like oh I had so much fun I had
so much fun let's do it again but I want
to do that math Square Garden where's
this stop because he's a rich white dude
who created Facebook
stole Facebook am I right let's not
let's go spade a spade here stole from
the twins that's why I paid him all the
money anyway you've never seen that show
the network the movie
um go up for me though Tim what did uh
Luke Thomas say
folks getting lost in the question of
rent as if that's the Central and the
issue is whether everyone else's absence
is the function of his presence not
whether that's that's predicated on
financial transactions yeah I don't
think I was really talking about the
money part of it it's just like as far
as like um
renting the place I think they're just
focused on like why do people have to be
missing and and you know I'm saying like
the fans can't be there that's my thing
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] if Mark Zucker
Zuckerberg's cage side do your thing
dude yeah I'll see you and Dan are boys
now whatever and he's you know but let
it be like a regular event and you know
yeah bro you're not the president United
States you're not Putin we don't need to
stop this thing because somebody's
coming with a [ __ ] bomb strapped to
their CH no one gives a [ __ ] about
Facebook my grandma digs Facebook but in
general like it's not like he's that
controversial you also
you know who's more controversial than
him and he's at every major pay-per-view
is Joe Rogan way more controversial than
Mark Zuckerberg
and he can rent it out what if Joe
didn't feel safe was like Hey man for
this UFC in Houston where the [ __ ]
they're at I don't want anybody around
people would be
outraged
this guy because he's a billionaire we
it's everyone's like okay that's cool
I don't think it's cool I also [ __ ] up
the fighters
for a lot of these Fighters feed off the
energy a Conor McGregor adjusting gechi
they feed off the energy of the fan base
so you better pray to God Mark
Zuckerberg isn't a fan of yours at your
next fight UFC you better pray to God
because he has all the resources and all
the means to make sure nobody else there
cheering for you
now latifi even said he got on the mic
he's like hey Mark Zucker and I got the
money give us a bonus dude so he wrote a
total casual confirmed bro rented out
the entire Apex and then only shows up
for the main card
no he didn't dude bro
no he didn't
that's so disrespectful hold on let me
get this straight oh my God this is
fantastic so at Die Hard MMA pod shout
out to Clint uh uh McLean McLean
so he was like we're told to confirmed
bro rent out the entire Apex that only
showed up for me card
it's like it's straight he rented out an
entire Arena and then just showed up
for the main card you didn't watch the
prelims
now
Mark Zuckerberg let me ask this
name 10 UFC fighters you can't let me
ask you this what the [ __ ] do you know
the difference between main card
Fighters and the prelims and you're
going to disrespect them right the
entire thing then show up late
are you out of your mind Joffrey
are you and no one told you quit doing
thumbs up thumbs down nobody's dying
quit doing that
there's no Tigers Zuckerberg doesn't
mean no Tigers involved
all right
this is insane to me Zuck is all of us
during these incredible UFC 61 by
Zuckerberg
they call him Zach
the UFC is like Zuck is liking this Zuck
but freaking Venom fan gear
Zuck but all his employees Venom finger
how far are we gonna go with this
Zuckerberg announces he's taking a fight
he's on UFC 290 pay-per-view it's just
it's
it's so insane it would never happen in
the other professional sport
where some billionaire can go uh I'm
recently into this I could never do it
hey check me out training was like oh
sick Jiu Jitsu shut up shut the [ __ ] up
it's not sick I'll show you sick you see
Mikey on one Championship Mark
Zuckerberg doing a basic [ __ ] white
Bell white belt arm bar everyone's like
oh my God this is sick why because a
nerd from Harvard was worth a billion
dollars all of a sudden found something
because he's bored as [ __ ] you guys are
hanging off his nuts it's insane dude
get over it it's not [ __ ] I've seen
seven-year-olds pull off fancier moves
he goes oh my God Mark Zuckerberg's into
Jujitsu man this is crazy now he's bored
as [ __ ] that's all this is here's all
the money in the world
I have a question if he was a lifelong
MMA fan would you feel differently yes
yep that's what that's what I think
triggers me
all of a sudden
and he's renting out the [ __ ] Arena
and then showing up late
are you out of your [ __ ] mind dude
you're not a fan if you're a fan of just
makes martial arts you jump at the
prelims
if you asked you know what the [ __ ] was
going you'd quit doing the [ __ ]
Gladiator thumbs up thumbs down thing
you'd ask Dana you'd quit asking Dana
how many people are gonna die tonight
that's an insane question Zuck
I I don't like to the UFC's like Zuck
he's every one of us cage like no he's
not he's Nothing Like Us he's not one of
us
now it's good to get new a new fan base
but I don't know if this is the way to
go UFC
they're letting Mark Zuckerberg pick the
winner yeah with a thumbs up thumbs down
and then his team's going to execute him
in the back
the best part about DFC events uh live
is the crowd going nattos like stay at
home bro what the [ __ ] that's from Ally
Quinta shout out I agree
so uh Nathan Corey uh at Nate rock
quarry but yes who of us hasn't bought
out entire Arena
it's called Arena's a little weird it's
more of a room it's kind of the size of
thick boy here if you ever seen it uh
yes Whoever has hasn't bought an entire
Arena to watch athletes bludgeon
themselves while we can't be bothered to
be among the unwashed masses I'd say for
the most of us the lap of luxury
involves buying brown mustard
that's hilarious
yeah
Zuckerberg ain't winning any over fans
doing this kind of [ __ ] you know now
that he gives a [ __ ] it's just insane
and he's also right so he didn't pull
his face off there's a robot there look
at him he's all oh my God this is
fantastic Dana White should K said okay
if I call you DW like what
it's just all so look at his eyes I know
they look like they're just
dead
yeah dude he's a robot
he looks like that guy from Star Trek
you know what I'm talking about you're
talking about data is it data it's data
okay that's what he looks like you're
talking about bro yeah he looks like
data
it's just yeah that dude this would yep
that's data he's a robot crap
he's a robot he's style Bender off the
new aliens
yeah I know it triggers me
I get it too though but it's a weird
thing when I try to break it down like
well he can do it but yeah some just
Rich billionaire not even a millionaire
liking something and like
yeah and then
Dan be like yeah do it and the people
yes yes and the fighters are just
[ __ ] CT up the [ __ ] gills bleeding
getting [ __ ] Starbucks employees have
more benefits the markets are really
like yes kill kill [ __ ] kill him it's
like what
in what world is this what world are we
living in what weird [ __ ] conspiracy
is this and then the other thing I think
that irks me even more is Dana lies
about it
and then B1 your mommy oh dude come on
that you saying Dana would actually do
that you'll see 279
Brendan needs a Handler
do I
or does your boy need a Handler
I'm not the one playing grab after his
Mark Zuckerberg letting him ran out
thick boy Studios shutting it down
for his entertainment you should have
ran that by me
right I don't need a Handler
these guys need a Handler somebody
should have gotten the air of Dana and
Mark Zuckerberg went hey hey you two
Rich privileged [ __ ] come over here let
me tell you something somebody should
have done this at UFC Institute hey you
two rich rich privileged fox come here
let me talk to you
do not ban the media do not not allow
fans to attend this event it affects the
fighters what's what's our first
priority here the fighters that's what
you say we know you're lying but this
makes it even worse
just because a guy's a billionaire and
stole a [ __ ] app called Facebook off
two twins
doesn't make this guy special he'd be a
game of fan last [ __ ] week quit
posting [ __ ] you're driving away your
fan base this isn't the way to go
Don't Call Him Zuck on your [ __ ]
social media either you don't know the
guy
we'll see how long he's gonna be into it
the card kind of sucked right
Mark Zucker I heard left pissed I made
that up I don't know probably at the
time of his life I'll tell you then his
wife
she was terrified
Jake to actually hitting each other and
then and then Mark Zucker Greg yes babe
they're hitting each other some of them
will die she's like they're gonna die
he's like hopefully if it's up to me
they will die and Daniel's like uh kill
them might be a little far-fetched my
man you know
it just it's not good dude it's because
who's next Who's Next who does Daniel
want to press next who can pay the toll
to watch these poor UFC fighters who are
underpaid like you wouldn't believe and
you have two of the richest men on the
[ __ ] planet
taking away the fan base the people that
built the UFC taking that away from the
fighters
if you're Mackenzie Dern granted she
lost so she has you know no leverage now
but she was probably like not happy
about it
she's probably not fan of Mark
Zuckerberg now my main event I can't
have a [ __ ] crowd all I hear is your
wife going oh my God stop it that's not
helping me you know what I'm saying it's
not good this isn't good this isn't a
good example to setment how far are we
going to take this Mark Zuckerberg
oh last week got a [ __ ] feather up
his ass it's like I like UFC I'm gonna
rent it out Daniel's like [ __ ] yeah good
choice nobody again I need a Handler
they need a Handler
everyone's okay with this we're just all
cool with it in here
all the fans listen here we're all cool
with this because this guy has money and
all of a sudden a fan
imagine
imagine any other team
on any other major sports League
name it let's say Marcus Mark Zuckerberg
becomes a [ __ ] Boston Red Sox fan
I was like Oh Aaron judges come in town
tonight he's gonna hit the 60 Second
Home Run set the record I want to be
there I want anybody else bothering me
I'm renting it out
called the Boston Red Sox right now this
is how it would go and this is how it
should go hi I'm here I'm Mark
Zuckerberg yes the robot I'm his manager
yeah uh he doesn't want to be bothered
and he wants to be the only one that
catches the ball uh when Aaron judge
hits the home run so he's going to rent
out the same how much will that be like
the [ __ ] I don't know 90 million
dollars he's like cool he'll pay that do
you accept wire Red Sox will shut the
[ __ ] up or never do that to our fans
click
hey Mark Zuckerberg he wants to collect
the new home run ball from Aaron judge
so he's just going to pay out every game
and then he's gonna if he could just not
show because he wants to sit behind the
catcher's box and then he hits the Home
Run he's going to run around the stadium
and grab it and pretend he caught it can
you guys do that for us MLB guy shut the
[ __ ] up no you seem like absolutely
how much do you want to pay absolutely
just don't suppress our [ __ ] post on
social media
it's insane
foreign
so I just saw this pop up right now but
um I guess during the broadcast over the
weekend at the UFC fights John attic
said pull out your testicles and take a
point referring to the fight between
um
Randy Brown and trinaldo I guess
Ronaldo's going for a takedown and Randy
Brown blatantly grabbed the fence and
the the referee didn't take a point or
anything I'm with Attica yes I'm with
that listen fence grab I poke nutshot
you take a point no warnings nothing
because it changes the dynamic of the
fight it only gives the guy who was
doing it the advantage
the other guy has a significant
disadvantage so how can you make that
right you take your point so even the
guy wins it's an 8-8 round so it doesn't
matter yeah
but going off the rules and there's guys
who are gonna Jon Jones there's guys who
are gonna eye poke and get away with it
because we know that there's gonna be
some leeway there I poke nut chop fence
grab Point automatically yeah no more
warnings
yeah but for John attic as a commentator
for the UFC standing on air like he's
the referee should have took out his
balls yeah that's pretty dope hell yeah
um your boy Ben roethl he had his debut
in bkfc this past weekend as well and he
knocked it out in 19 seconds I'll show
you the Clipper here
yeah he is a Savage
he's also born to do this now Zuckerberg
you like violence you like people don't
you see rent out bkfc bro rent that out
you think your wife wanted to [ __ ]
hurl at the UFC which nothing happened
go to Bare knuckle
kill somebody
that's what you want Caesar
Joffrey if that's what you're looking
for be KFC do one in Russia
Russia might even be doing that [ __ ]
with tigers and I think they've done
that Russia is probably the craziest one
yeah they do all those things
they shout out to Ben roethl doing the
damn thing
all right so there's some beef between
Conor McGregor and Michael Bisping now
because Conor McGregor made some sort of
point about acting and then uh I'll just
show you the quote here uh so he deletes
the Tweet which they delete this is all
uh predicated so when they post
something they delete it they know
people are going to screenshot it makes
it bigger and then also when it's not on
their feed sponsoring stuff can't go
back and look at it ah yeah because
think about it if you're
whatever major sponsor let's say it's
proper 12 right
they they're not familiar with this
stuff so they're like you see what
Connor said I'm like no they go to
Twitter I'm like I don't see anything
the suits they don't get it uh so he put
all these little torps want to be actors
now little torps there's only one Mac
Daddy Bad to the Bone but with a good
heart action with Jake Gyllenhaal or
rom-com with Jessica Parker Sarah
Jessica Parker Bisping member that show
you were in yeah me neither
she's taking a job at bisping's acting
well here's the thing here
um
going after Biz being you know I'm a big
uh Connor fan definitely a Bisping fan
but that's how you know Bisping is doing
well so if he references Biz being that
means Bisping is getting a lot of roles
right can you call him out because
you're an acting who's the one MMA guy
who's doing more act than anybody
Michael Bisping so you go after him
right it'd be like if Conor's getting a
comedy
there's only one former UFC fighter
headline in comedy shows selling out
theaters and uh clubs it's me so who's
he going to go after
and go after guys not doing well you
know I go after a guy who can't sell
tickets you go after a guy who's killing
that's Michael Bisby if I'm Michael
business thanks dude tying on the right
track
he didn't say any of these other guys
Woodley's in movies
nobody doing like Bisping though he's
been doing very well for himself man
because I mean I think when he found out
about this he was on set in Bulgaria
shooting a movie
um so it's been quite so Bismarck has
really been in Bulgaria film movie the
world's scariest man uh soon got one of
McGregor's comments and replied his
podcast he's all excited he's had his
first beard he's doing a Big Show with
Jake Gyllenhall God bless him good for
[ __ ] you well done why have you got
to throw shade my way I get it I don't
get it uh I don't get it well no Bisping
it's a good thing buddy it means you're
crushing it because for him to mention
you means you're in his Lane he's
getting into the lane you're the you're
the North Star you're the UFC fighter
who's
parlayed it into the movies there's been
other guys like
Chuck Liddell was an Entourage right
you've had GSP trying to do it but they
played those tough guys and it's always
that stuff like bisbee's doing real
active so to me this is a uh a good
thing for my kabisby so uh I guess so I
don't get it just make sure you've got
your bodyguard ready next time you come
I want to talk some [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] and this is how uh Connor
responded he says business you'll do
[ __ ] God Connor it's funny you'll do
[ __ ] all you little Sprinter I'll cave
your head in [ __ ] fighter [ __ ] actor
foreign
crazier oh it kept going yeah so Connor
sent a voice message to Bisping and Biz
being posted it no no uh I don't know
how did they get it I think it's like an
internet voice message I'm not sure but
oh so he did like a voice note as a
tweet something like that that's lit I
don't know you could do that
all right check it out
man yeah
yeah
security a little sausage everything
I have security set you up
we're just there when you're in Vegas
again pal
the latex funny part
keep my name out of your [ __ ] melt
again I need to be threatening behavior
or I'll walk through your front door
you're blinking on it you little dope
you're the man's yeah go back go back
where you belong here little clown you
little Sprinter
hmm
[Music]
behaving weird as of late yeah yeah
again for Bisbee it's a good thing you
want to go to war it's like War dude you
you come why are we going to war are you
calling me out for acting I'm just doing
my thing man this has been scratching it
and uh do you want to go to war yeah do
you want to [ __ ] War we'll go to war
with you yes security a little sausage
of a thing it's just the way he talks is
hilarious
um I'll have security set you up where
do you stay when you're in Vegas again
pal little Apex [ __ ] pad
keep my name out your mouth and any type
of threatening behavior I'll walk
through your front door yep Laguna site
of bisbee's Home in California Danny
lives in Laguna that's how you know he's
crushing you ever been a lagoon
beautiful if I was in this business I'd
be out there
um you little dope yep the max I don't
know I mean go back where you belong
your little Clowny little Sprinter
interesting yeah and then biswing you
know said he would [ __ ] him up which
middleweight champion of the world you
get here also this is yeah people get
confused too
again
Conor going out busy means Biz being
crushing it because he's when he thought
of acting he thought of bizwing that's a
good thing I think Kami think of me
that's a good thing that means you're
doing something right so when Conor goes
after him it's a good thing but these
guys when they talk [ __ ] to these bigger
guys like a Bisping like a Danny Cormier
all right man like you're poking the
[ __ ] bear and you're lucky these guys
are busy and they're retired and they're
doing a thing but y'all must have forgot
these guys do have that in them if you
run into them you can have some problems
man and then it's going to be oh why
would bism do that to economies fight at
45 it's like oh no oh now you're upset
now oh so if DC [ __ ] up an idea dude
you were a [ __ ] heavyweight champ of
the world man why would you take out
Nate Diaz he's fighting at 55 it's like
I know I know no we we're aware of uh
the when he was professional what uh
weight class he fought at but do you
realize the [ __ ] he talked to him
so if those guys decide to answer back
don't start defending them going yeah oh
you beat up a smaller guy that's how
this goes they're talking [ __ ] yeah be
careful what you asked for those guys
have that in them
all right moving on past this uh his
about announcement Shane Burgos damn
that's again my damn burko said CIA UFC
move fight Marlon Mariah yep that's a
great [ __ ] fight tough fight for
chamber girls
episode November 25th that's a great
fight great fight and then also with pfl
apparently they're going to do
pay-per-view now and split half of the
revenue they get from it with the
fighters
Hmm this is what their president who do
they have I mean besides uh
Harrison Harrison should get all the
money who else is going to be a main
draw on the starting 2022 outside of the
league format we're going to put on two
super fights as today we're open for
business we're going to do two things
different
Fighters will be true economic Partners
in their fights 50 50 for pay-per-view
shares they will share 50 on the revenue
of their Pay-Per-View fights never
happen in the history of MMA number one
number two to now in pay-per-view it's
been one company town it's now a two
company town if you're a fighter you
have a choice when you have a choice you
have opportunity before the only company
that put a successful pay-per-views on
with UFC and they're great at it
starting 2023 there's a second company
yeah but we're also owned by the UFC
well
that's good for the fighters but here's
a weird thing so one of the headliners
is uh or the headliner Kayla Harrison
versus Larissa Pacheco three she's
already beat her two times and that's
gonna be like the headlining
Pay-Per-View event that's the problem
yeah there's no there's nothing for
Harrison out there it's like all right
yeah
that's the problem are you trying to
beat up twice I'll pay for that I know I
don't know it's gonna go pay-per-view
wise um Davidson figuero Brandon Moreno
four is being targeted for you take my
money take my money
January 21st in Brazil
take my money all right here's another
couple quick fight announcements Derrick
Lewis versus Sergey Spivak and I looked
at Derek's record it's been tough lately
last last time
uh Spivak one is last two
then we have walking Buckley versus
Chris Curtis I like that fight and this
is Joaquin Buckley's record
and then so he has the last fight he
lost and Chris Curtis last fight he lost
that's a funner fight yeah and then we
have this real quick
oh do you remember John Hathaway he was
from UFC hell yeah so it's been eight
years and now he's back to fighting
again not in the UFC but he's back to
M.A I guess he had ulcerative colitis
Crohn's disease oh well and it's just
messed him up for that's what now yeah
he has like a
something else I think I thought Brock
had Crohn's too no no something else
[ __ ] I forgot was called but it's an
intestinal yeah yeah I think you have
diarrhea pretty much yeah
really is that diarrhea is that fancy
term for diarrhea
oh yeah that's not funny it said
something about irritation to the ballot
and all that stuff too so dude you're
talking about diarrhea 24 7.
I'm not mad at dyrus sometimes the
problem is it just it just when it comes
when it's good it's good well the
problem with diarrhea is like you you
like you can't hold it
like I mean it's a little it's a fire
alarm
it's a fire alarm but if you get rid of
everything at one time it feels amazing
yeah
you're doing the [ __ ]
uh so here's another fight announcement
Kevin Kelvin gaslin versus Master Dean
hemavov and I checked out kelvin's
record as of late it's pretty crazy it's
been very tough yeah I mean Grant is
about the who's who exactly
and this dude's killing it right now
three fight win streak
be a fun fight mm-hmm
Eve let's go here real quick
so Javier Mendez says that islamako is
basically the best lightweight fighter
ever even better than khabib
potentially
to say potentially he's just saying like
you said now because after off who he's
beat he's not now Javier has a different
perspective because he sees him in the
training room and I've told you I've
heard the story about mock Jeff and
train room it's insane everyone tells
you better in khabib we just haven't
seen that inside the Octagon yeah and he
hasn't beat those guys like his biggest
wins dos anjos I'm already sees the best
[ __ ] lightweight of all time go to on
record saying as lightweight he has
hands down he's hands down the number
one of all time
I wish it said potentially because
there's no way you could say he's the
best of all time maybe from what he sees
inside the gym I know but he doesn't say
that he's just saying right now yeah of
all time like not even close Bubba
but Javier knows this [ __ ] we shall see
Hamza remember he posted that thing
about 185 recently uh like five days
later that was the first one he posted
185 so we thought it was gonna move up
to 185 but most recently he posted this
calling out colby colby Covington says
next
that's a great fight yeah so I think
that might actually happen I'm not the
slight favorite right here
hmm
minus 160 for hamzat that's a hell of a
fight
hell of a fight what if the book that in
December
that'd be good
and then this is DC's
comment on it for sure he's the most
difficult match yeah but for sure that's
why I like to fight so this is DC
speaking not me Kobe Covington can match
Hamza at most of those years except for
size uh Kobe Kevin can match Hamza and
most of theirs where we will generally
say Hamza has the advantages wrestling
cardio well I would say at this point
the cardio Advantage is Colby I would
love to hear what DC thinks uh hamzat
has proved that he has cardio go what
fight do it burns no yeah that's the
only closest one which other fight yeah
I can go through Colby's cray and give
you very fine examples how he's a cardio
[ __ ] machine there's only one fighter
in the history of the UFC has better
better cardio than uh Kobe Compton it's
come out Usman that's it
uh that might have a little bit of an
issue
let's see what Kobe can't match is the
power of homs that correct that's where
you might have a bit of an issue but as
he has shown a number of occasions he
may not most powerful guy uh Kobe's Pace
his pressure and his real spirit and
decided to win fights along compute the
high so we have all seen him melt people
if you recall the guild Burns fight
hamzat was starting to fatigue as the
fight went longer so experience to match
up that what could potentially the most
difficult for hamzat I'm all in if you
make the weight I agree 100 I'm balling
gotta make the weight though but DC is
not no dummy to the game he knows what's
up he's saying if you recall you know
guilt Burns fight Hamza was trying to
fatigue as the fight went longer yeah
anything else to go against Colby the
problem is is
you know one one guy's extreme Advantage
is cardio one guy's extreme advantages
power so if it doesn't go five rounds
and if you're Colby you definitely
needed to go past the Third
great [ __ ] fight yeah definitely
great fight we kind of knew this was
gonna happen but Aspen live was finally
released from UFC after missing weight
and it was like it's just time it's you
know if you miss way it's the one thing
we don't put up with he says he likes
her she's sweet
oh my goodness I I can't write this [ __ ]
it
it's all pointing my direction and I
might want to die in that Hill I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm just saying it adds
value to my conspiracy the longer this
goes on the Zuckerberg the line about
Zuckerberg the line about guys missing
weight this the cutting out because
you're missing weight hamzaad had a
great week he missed wait that's okay
weird
yeah I don't know I don't know why you
have to know though I don't know why he
had to even denied
complete [ __ ] you didn't have to say
that you could just yeah say whatever
we're gonna hear him yeah he'd be like
yeah nothing yeah he called my team he
said I don't know he want to rent it out
it's [ __ ] weird we've never done
before we've never done before we see
how it goes yeah I don't know why oh so
this is a marker Monday posted this I
guess it was an interview from before
Jorge Mazda talking about your dude boy
nickel and it's pretty cool here
training with Bo nickel I know he's been
a part of your training camp for this
fight how has that been going
I was so damn good
so much better than me he's also 197
pounder and uh I mean he doesn't use a
string for me but his fluidity his his
ability I saw Bo
um since his freshman year in college I
was actually a Madison Square Garden for
the ncaa's and he was a finalists there
then after that he wanted to win it like
three times so I know a lot about this
guy and like
I was more like excited to meet him and
he was excited to meet me you know since
I've met him and um we clicked we worked
well I show him what I can on the
Striking and he literally just opens the
book on the wrestling shows me
everything everything about the culture
that that makes him so phenomenal you
know besides his work ethic and his in
his creativity I mean the guy's just
like a brain man he dissects every
position
here's your problem everywhere man so
the work is it's going you know I'm not
going to say it's going good for me but
it's going tell you oh you think Mazda
knows a thing or two about fighting
just co-signed bow nickel
yes he did uh let's pass this one oh so
this is a pretty cool knockout that I
saw this is ax kick I always thought an
ax kick is kind of like one of those
weapons that it doesn't seem it's gonna
be like that much leverage or anything
see that they were yeah but this is
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
Christ boom
they're just playing the perfect spot
Jesus Christ and then check this out
this guy winds up on this elbow
whoop
that is tricky because you think he's
gonna throw a punch and just spin an
elbow yeah and the guy had to come into
and this is a pretty pretty crazy
guillotine
God damn how strong is he it's amateur
because they have their shin guards on
oh that's amateur yeah that's why you
see the stream guard he's just holding
him in the air that's pretty crazy
um it looks like you really tweaked his
neck there and this is this has happened
before in you know different cages but
this is probably the craziest one I've
seen so far where they both fly out of
the cage
at least the case didn't break
it's just they didn't lock the door I
know that's what it looks like right
there's someone just messed up it didn't
lock the door I forgot to put the
the there's like a metal thing they put
on the door like a latch the gatekeeper
was just like getting a cup of coffee I
said my bad
and we just had liver King on fighting
the kid this is him at the Bellator
event he did a video uh talking about
um Paulo Costa right yeah but that's him
eating liver with Paula Casa and patriki
Pitbull
and Casa also eats liver yeah
oh no look at him
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
I almost threw up myself
[Music]
it's tough man I can't do it is it the
consistency of it or just the taste
everything everything see it tastes like
Sashimi like you're in what world
uh this is a real quick one
kyota Yan bought his uh coach his dream
truck which is pretty cool of them oh
that's dope but it's also with that
block asset so they did it together so I
don't know if it's like a publicity type
of thing either but yeah they're too
much music in the background so I can't
play it but not good that was pretty
cool though
and I saw this too that Joe Rogan used
to bet on UFC even when he was part of
UFC he didn't know it was illegal or
anything back then hey it wasn't they
have rules oh okay no Rogue knows his
[ __ ] they can only talk about fight I
mean clearly he knows the [ __ ] yeah so I
just plays quick for you I used to be on
UFC really even when I was commentating
I bet on it early on I'm like this is
probably not legal one of my business
partner he would come to a lot of the
fights and I would give him he would
gamble so when I stopped gambling I
would just say bet and we were at like
84 success rate it was so crazy
84 success rate which is not I know
um I don't know what this is about but
I'll just play for it this is Dana White
wheel and I am putting together the
biggest slap competition of all time so
if you have ever professionally slapped
or you think you can email a video and
your information to our casting team at
slapcast at pilgrimmediagroup.com or
just hit the Lincoln bio
it's awkward yeah so I wonder if it's
going to be for I don't know definitely
not just the UFC trying to stay relevant
it's like you know then with the now
boys them you know paying that little
dude from uh Dagestan to be in the arena
uh what else can we do steam's like dude
what about a slap contest that's getting
big you mean the thing Logan Paul used
for marketing years ago
what else you got all right so Jake Paul
is saying that so he has a podcast now
um I forgot what the name is but so
there's a podcast and he's saying that
he's working with the big MMA promotion
and he wants to do MMA within a year he
had some relationship with pfl for a
while oh really
so the BS the Jake Paul podcast I'm
gonna do the big organization right now
and a whole thing in the MMA that has to
do with me fighting we're going to have
an announcement soon wow yep and then he
says here I want to do it with there you
go he's going to AK that's good for him
I'll do with Javier Mendez see to train
me I'll go to American kickbox carry I
probably need a year year and a half to
get the kicks down I already know jiu
jitsu interesting that's alarming I want
to be able to do in there and at least
check kicks I already know how to
wrestle
interesting
be fun to see him in there yeah they
give me the UFC
UC is not doing that I hear you uh
remember we talked about this last week
that Eddie Hearn is suing Jake Paul for
100 million dollars yeah so I guess Jake
Paul was on the same podcast saying that
he's gonna debunk it somehow like it's
like it's BS that he's not suing him
yeah
we'll get into the hearing situation
probably next episode there's just too
much to unravel there and we've got too
much [ __ ] going on this episode we're
gonna debunked that too right here and
if you guys don't know Eddie her and
sued me so I'm going to go you know that
next week to hold the whole Eddie Hearn
situation what's going on there
when's this podcast come out it already
came out and he had freaking uh Tyron
Woodley on there that makes sense yeah
so him and Tyrone were talking about
their fight and then plus the Anderson
Silva Jake Paul fight Tyron possibly
boxing KSI
interesting but um
did he did so it already came out and he
talked about the Eddie Hearn thing no he
said he's gonna do in her feature
episode and that's why I know he said
he's gonna do on the next one yeah
that's what I'm saying when does it come
out oh that I don't know yeah that's
what I'm saying okay when does that come
out that's what I'm here I'm gonna [ __ ]
about this yeah I'm not sure
um all right so this one real quick this
is going back to what Dana White said
about the whole thing how the guy
whatever lab could figure out how many
more years he has to live so I'll just
play it for you I want you to watch this
what show is this on this is inside the
Apex I think and they know when you're
gonna die and they're right within a
month so I'm like wait a minute this guy
can tell me when I'm gonna die and be
right within a month that was your hook
I became obsessed so I went down there
they did my blood work he said if you
keep doing what you're doing right now
and you stay on this trajectory
you got 10.4 years I said Dana I can see
that you can't sleep through the night I
would wake up in the middle of the night
and throw up almost every night and I
said I'd be very surprised if it's not
painful for you to bend down entire
shoes right now and he and he knows
[ __ ] way he slammed the table down
he's like you've got to be kidding me
you're starting to freak me out my legs
were so [ __ ] up that I couldn't put my
socks on in the morning I was like a
tenth of a point away from being
diabetic he said you do exactly what I
tell you to do for 10 weeks and I
guarantee you I'll change your life so I
was then you have to understand I don't
fall into all this hippie [ __ ] you
know I don't do any of this [ __ ] I'm
like Average Joe real guy okay this guy
has changed my life in 10 weeks I don't
snore anymore and and I sleep seven
eight hours a night now how much weight
have you lost if you don't mind me 30
pounds I feel like I'm 35 years old
again check that out it looks great
there's somebody who's listening right
now who are going through the same
things that I did horrible don't
steroids right sleep apnea hey guys got
steroids steroids and diet the guy too
oh so the show's called well the guy was
like listen you're gonna die in 10 years
I'll narrow it down to the month unless
you take my program for one million
dollars a month
Dan's like say less
let me guess eat more vegetables less
carbs less sugar take these steroids get
sleep
and the guy's face didn't he look like
the kind of face that's kind of like oh
I'll take furniture he looks like the
guy you don't trust
it's so weird you could just see his
face and looks like he can't oh why
because he's scared Dennis and you're
gonna die in 10 years if you don't take
my program and pay me weird but the good
thing is Dana got healthy he does look
damn he looks really good he looks
fantastic I don't care what it is maybe
the guy is selling snake girl but the
thing is is if it got anybody Dana
anybody any of the public out there to
live a healthier life it works it's not
snake girl it works cool
the thing where snake oil saying 10
years I'll put it down to the month
that's not real right guys that's not I
just don't know how you can do it
because then everybody in the world
would take that test I'm like oh man
Mike says 30 years like I would take the
test I'd be afraid if they can tell you
exactly if you through your blood type
how long you have to live
that's not real right everybody right
right
real is Zuckerberg renting out the Apex
Center okay yeah
that is real
uh this is the last one I thought this
is funny this is from uppercuts TV it
says uh this is so funny you saw it it
says Bruce Buffer must prepare for UFC
280. look at the name I know the names
are insane you know what's funny though
is when I did my test for Fox Sports bin
analyst I swear to God the names were
like this but worse it was all
Brazilians I was like wait what you guys
know I struggle with saying names it was
this is a nightmare
Bruce is gonna smash this though yeah
he's great yeah God those names are oh
it's just funny holy [ __ ] yeah even
Japanese name or two oh it's tough
all right um all we have left is there's
one fight over this weekend and it's
Alistair over in versus butterheart 3
for Glory Kickboxing the co-main event
with Van zos she's a beast she's fun too
but [ __ ] badahari over him doing the
damn thing both older I'll watch it
though you know those legendary
fights both I think they're with one and
one yeah both knocked each other up yeah
yeah he knocked out straight up Uber
rain like yeah it was juicy juicy
that's Saturday October 8th that's what
it says this is a Glory website
I'll watch it same I need something to
do is that it that's it
all right kids uh your boys hitting the
road I am in San Jose next Thursday
Friday Saturday San Jose Improv San Jose
California October 13th through the 15th
and then uh the week after that that
weekend
um in Salt Lake City Wise Guys one of my
favorite clubs in the world Wise Guys is
October 20th through the 22nd and then
we end September oh there they got it up
J shop is on it he's listening Calgary
is October 27th that's a Thursday and
that show's almost sold out so we added
a show on Friday at the rooftop downtown
Calgary that's October 27th through 28th
in Calgary November is Texas heavy San
Antonio Houston now I'm in uh Jeffrey
Dahmer's hometown of Milwaukee November
18th through 19th
then we end the year in Providence Rhode
Island in Washington DC all right but um
San Jose you're up next week after that
Salt Lake Dynamic Calgary in October get
your tickets at thick boy.com love you
guys be safe be nice to each other
thanks for watching liking subscribing
new Green Room Diaries will be dropping
on bread and chaub uh YouTube not thick
boys so that'd be Brent shop comedy
YouTube we have a whole Boston bit going
on there on Aaron Hernandez and how the
city's changing it's a fun one like
subscribe there if you can love you guys
thanks for everything be nice to each
other I'm out